kader abderrahim directeur de recherche
à l'ipp se situe prospective et sécurité
en europe
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on vient de le
dire le demi frère du roi le prince rama
une quinzaine de personnes sont accusées
d'avoir comploté contre le régime c'est
en tout cas la version officielle des
autorités y at il des doutes autour de
ces accusations en tout cas il ya des
questions ça apparaît vraiment que mon
lutte d'influencé interne à la famille
royale comme il a été souligné dans
votre reportage
le prince comme ça et le demi-frère du
roi abdallah et on se souvient qu'au
moment de la transition dynastique
après la mort du roi hussein il y avait
eu un rapide aller retour du roi cuisine
qui était malade et soigné aux états
unis afin qu'il change l'ordre de
succession parce que le prince
chassaigne son frère aîné était son
frère cadet pardon était perçu par les
américains comme et on francophile et
donc beaucoup trop proche de la france
et pas à même de défendre de manière
irréversible les intérêts américains
donc cela ressemble terriblement à nu
dynastique pour le pouvoir qui pourrait
provoquer des tensions à l'intérieur de
la famille régnante et rappelle je vous
tiens à souligner également qu'on est
ici en jordanie avec la dynastie
hachémite dans la même configuration que
pour les pétromonarchies du golfe
c'est à dire une famille régnante et des
princes nombreux qui sont issus de
différents mariages qui n'ont pas
nécessairement le même père ou la même
mère et guy et ça alimente des tensions
et surtout des rivalités entre les
hommes qui peuvent prétendre au trône
justement la reine anne morin après la
défense de son fils elle a d'ailleurs
dénoncé des calomnies
mais on a l'impression tout de même que
le prince ramsey n'a vraiment n'a jamais
vraiment digéré le fait d'avoir perdu
son titre de prince héritier oui c'est
l'un des éléments il l'est il est
effectivement héritier du trône et
aujourd'hui il semblerait que les
critiques qu'il a formulées depuis
maintenant plusieurs années contre
l'exercice du pouvoir par son demi frère
noir delà mais également l'entourage du
roi sur les questions de corruption de
prévarication de de torture aussi contre
les opposants
es tu un effet assez dévastateur dans la
partie parmi l'entourage du roi et il a
été contraint d'agir pour éliminer ceux
qui aujourd'hui lui apparaît comme une
menace dont le prince hamza est un homme
qui n'hésite pas à s'exprimer y compris
publiquement pour critiquer la gestion
mais peut-être qu'il est également un
peu trop impatient et c'est aujourd'hui
ce qu'il paie son caractère tempétueux
se retourne un peu contrôle vite on est
aussi dans une situation dans un
contexte régional très instable et il
est probable que l'administration
la nouvelle administration américaine et
fait en sorte que ce royaume qui va
fêter son centenaire très bientôt alors
que la dynastie hachémite régnait sur
oran trois pays arabes
hind est aujourd'hui présent que en
jordanie qu est probablement le roi delà
d'eux voulait que sa famille continue à
transmettre ce royaume qui relativement
stable même si il y à d'énormes
problèmes internes notamment à la
question des réfugiés palestiniens et
qui aujourd'hui à laquelle il faut
ajouter la question des nombreux
un million et demi de mêlée où on s'est
pas très bien réfugiés syriens
justement avec cette affaire est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à des
vision dans le pays c'est fort peu
probable je ne crois pas et je crois pas
non plus qu'il soit de l'intérêt du roi
d'aller au plus loin dans la répression
autre son demi-frère et l'entourage de
son demi frère
par conséquent il me semble que il va y
avoir un moment sans doute de tension et
de surveillance accrue contre
l'opposition qu'elle soit interne en
jordanie ou bien externes allant
notamment en grande bretagne et mais je
ne tenais pas l'intérêt du roi
aujourd'hui de déstabiliser son pays
d'autant que la menace de la
reconstitution de dèche sur le plan
logistique est aussi un élément qu'il
faut garder en tête et il est évident
que britanniques et américains sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement attentif à ce
petit pays qui jouent un rôle charnière
et qui est l'un des éléments clés de la
stabilité à la porte du moyen orient
mais également du processus de sécurité
américain merci beaucoup en tout cas
quand à l'intérim d'avoir à répondre à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'ipp seul
institut prospective et sécurité en
europe